hey youtubers it's Charlie so the writer
on Captain Marvel said the character is
going to get a new origin story in the
marvel universe because it's too similar
to another characters so here's a quick
breakdown of what's going on
most of you may have some idea for her
origin story in the comics it's been
red coned couple times the most recent
version is that she basically got caught
in this giant explosion with the Creed
device and infused her with all this
cosmic energy so then she took up the
title captain marvel as a way to honor
the original captain mar-vell the creed
version of the character so it gets a
little complicated with all the
different versions of miss marvel is who
the character carol danvers used to be
in the comics in Captain Marvel so
there's a bunch of ms Marvel's there's a
bunch of Captain Marvel's the movies are
just going to simplify all that the
writer of the movies so that they will
change her origin story a little bit to
fit with what they've been doing in the
movies
meaning as we've all kind of predicted
that they're gonna tie it to an infinity
gems because she's one of the most
powerful Marvel heroes that comes from
Earth in the only way to put her on the
level of scarlet witch and even like
vision whose I mean he's an AI is to
give her an origin story that matches
that power level which means infinity
stone but as with all things in the
movies when they change the plot of
certain stories they always try to honor
the comic book version with a bunch of
easter eggs so I'm expecting a lot of
captain mar-vell easter eggs when
she gets her powers but no idea when
that's going to happen during the movie
we only know that she's going to appear
and then she'll go onto her spin-off
film captain marvel after that I've
already done a video for her origin
story i'll put a link in the description
what we really need to talk about now
though is which infinity gem would she
get her powers from would be the mind
gem like vision the only way to do that
would probably to rip it out of his
skull so I don't know if they want to do
that
I mean they'll have to do it eventually
because he knows we'll need it to
assemble the Infinity Gauntlet which I
do think that he will achieve during
infinity war but the only other gems
that haven't been used yet are the time
gem and the soul gem so if you guys don't
know who adam warlock is in the comics
he eventually goes on to call himself
the ultimate Avenger so he's a good
character but it means a lot of
complicated backstory because he has an
evil persona called the mages it was
involved in a really big infinity war
comic book storyline
that involve a nose assembling the
gauntlet then it's spinning into a bunch
of other big cosmic stories is it's like
this really big cosmic part of the
Marvel Universe that the movies haven't
even touched on, you do not need to worry
about it at all but i think the captain
marvel will kind of fill that Adam
warlock ultimate Avenger roll meaning
that Adam warlock who possessed the soul
gem in the comics will probably go to
Captain Marvel so odds are right now
that if she gets her power from an
infinity gem it will be the soul gem i
think the time jen is going to be Doctor
Strange relative but there's a number of
different things that they could do so
here's my big question for you which gem
do you think is going to give captain
marvel her powers in Avengers infinity
war and at what point in the movie do
you think that's going to happen they
could do it a couple different ways one
they could do the Spider Man Thing like
they didn't Civil War like when he
showed up for the first time he had
already become spider-man he just didn't
have a really amazing stark Tech costume
yet so in the movie we could meet her as
this test pilot who has already gotten
her powers and is trying to figure them
out or we meet Air Force pilot Carol
Danvers and she somehow comes into
contact with the infinity gems and gets
her powers while the Avengers are nearby
like during the course of events in the
movie so I know there's a whole lot of
questions like everybody wants to know
what's going on but the good thing is is
we have a couple movies before we get to
infinity war so a lot of what happens
during those will determine what happens
next
so once we see some of the post-credit
scenes in the next Marvel movies will
have a better idea for what's going on
with the Infinity Gauntlet the infinity
gems because that will largely determine
what ends up happening at the beginning
of Avengers infinity war how that gem
comes into contact with carol danvers
right now the only movies that I'm
expecting to directly address that are
thor ragnarok you know because of this
teaser they gave us a comic-con who is
the purple man in the chair trying to
assemble the glove who is this person
and then dr. strange because that gets
into multiverse really cosmic
altered states of the universe stuff you
know very very big ideas and that's what
if they do work is going to be it's
going to be the culmination of a bunch
of the biggest ideas in the Marvel
Universe so dr. strange coming in
November we might get some Inklings of
infinity war stuff it's just is really
going to introduce the multiverse into
the Marvel Universe everybody knows
about the multiverse I mean it's really
simple concept
but they haven't really addressed in the
movies yet so technically if the movies
don't address something it doesn't exist
like if something doesn't get mentioned
or they don't hit something or it's not
in the subtext it doesn't exist so until
we see dr. strange there is no
multiverse yet but I mean we know it's
there just because they told us it's
there but surprisingly guardians of the
galaxy isn't going to get into too much
infinity war stuff it's largely
self-contained the way James Gunn
explains it
no Thanos no infinity gems in that movie
you know even though they're gonna be
dealing with some very cosmic ideas in
funny enough you know captain marvel in
like the one previous run of the comic
book she crossed over there was a big
star Lord story with his father this big
galactic empire it went a little crazy
but it's just funny the captain marvel
just did a big crossover with the
guardians of the galaxy and we're
getting ready for infinity war which will
be that Guardians crossover but you
don't need to read any of those comics
to understand what's going on as long as
you have a basic idea for who the
character is like where she comes from
she comes from the military kind of you
know her power levels and what her
psychology is like how is she different
from the other aventures in the way she
tackles problems the simplest way I
could explain her is that she's from the
military like Captain America but she's
like Captain America on 10 cups of
coffee like she just like very quick to
make decisions very sure of the course
of action that she wants to take and she
largely deals in absolutes because her
biggest job right now is taking care of
the entire planet protecting it from
external alien threats so everything
that comes across her desk is a
life-or-death situation so you can't
begin to understand why it is she so
hardcore even though a lot of her energy
flows from the same place of Captain
America is the captain america's played
a little bit more like a boy scout she
comes off as like a little more
argumentative than that and obviously
she's a lot more powerful than Captain
America so that's why I'm just gonna
call her like the 10 cups of coffee
version of Captain America but I'm
expecting brie Larson like she's an
amazing actors to infuse a lot of her
own energy into the character so we'll
learn all about the pathos of movie
captain marvel when we see her an
infinity war but in the way we saw
Scarlet Witch for the first time in
avengers age of ultron then we got to
like the next movie civil war and that
really dealt with her psychology i would
expect the same type of treatment with
the captain marvel character will learn
a little bit about what's going on in
her head during infinity war then when
they get to her solo movie still really
go for the deep dive like you really
learn what she's all about the next real
big question is is who is going to be
the villain of the captain marvel movie
that's something you want to talk about
like a whole of the video but just think
about it this way if they want to keep
the movie on earth it's gonna be really
hard for them to do some of her bigger
villains because a lot of them come from
the Kree in the comics and that's very
galactic so just remains to be seen how
earth-based the captain marvel movies
going to be there just like a couple big
buildings that they have not done from
the comics aim is a big Captain Marvel
villain but i don't know if they would
often do MODOK I mean we're almost at
the place where we could get away with
doing MODOK they might borrow villains
from some of the other movies and it
might just be an extension of what
happens during infinity war it will
definitely have to address what happens
infinity war because in the timeline
will be happening after so i definitely
think they'll be at least a little bit
of galactic stuff happening in her movie
but I just can't wait to see the other
Avengers try to figure out what to do
with her like Tony can barely handle
Scarlet Witch and vision right now
what is he gonna do when another gem
power person comes along who's be like
oh my god I'm gonna call in sick today
and just go to queens and hang out with
spider-man and his hot aunt may if you
couldn't already tell i'm very excited
about that spider-man movie so they'll
be a new spider-man video price sometime
in the next week but tomorrow new game
of thrones so be sure to subscribe to
get it there supposed to be a walking
dead season 7 preview so i'll probably
doing a video for that to later that
night so while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about Captain Marvel's
backstory in the comics and you can
click here for the Black Panther
comic-con teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight